a free man taking his first steps into a
new South Africa from prisoner to
president Nelson Mandela's 1990 release
from jail signaled the end of South
Africa's racist policy of apartheid he
would go on to become the country's
first truly democratically elected
leader hi what is that man gonna do
hereby sir to be faithful to the
Republic of South Africa
born in the small village of m'avez Oh
to a local chief Mandela was one of 13
children and the first member of his
family to attend school in the 1940s he
began opposing the white minorities
policy of apartheid laws that segregated
society and made coloured South Africans
second-class citizens at first Mandela
was inspired by Gandhi's approach of
nonviolent resistance but as white South
Africa became more aggressive so did he
as the head of the armed wing of the
African National Congress the ANC
Mandela led violent sabotage attacks and
was arrested and tried in 1962 he would
spend 27 years in jail but he was never
forgotten
eventually international and internal
pressure led President FW de Klerk to
announce apartheid would be dismantled
and Mandela would walk free but rather
than seek retribution Nelson Mandela
reached out to his former oppressors
tried to heal a divided nation in 1993
he and de Klerk shared the Nobel Peace
Prize white a fellow South Africans
and one them believe this and that we
appreciated the congregation they have
made towards the development of this
country in 1994 he voted for the first
time with millions of his fellow black
South Africans vetted by global leaders
and celebrities he became a statesman an
international icon for South Africa he
was
symbol of the country it wanted to be
despite struggles with poverty racism
and AIDS feel any hydrant feel
bitterness free of any idea of nation
many will remember this Mandela
celebrating South Africa's a place on
the world stage as it hosted the 2010
soccer world cup he's a great lad africa
loves him a simple tribute from a child
sums up his place in South Africans
hearts the reefs thank you for our
dignity